[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour je suis perdre la voix hier bon
sinon il a trop attendu un dos d'âne et
paf un réchaud public donc c'était plus
petit que 2 euros j'aurai une ps2
d'euros doit aller avec tout cas cette
fois
[Musique]
avant de décider
pour qui j'ai joué
à vélo
ou
[Musique]
même qu'est ce tu fais
du hockey
tu fais quoi manger
je peux voir ce que ca y est mais maman
mais maman laisse moi voir laisse-moi
goûter c'est quoi tu verras sur ma
surprise pourquoi on adhésion prix là à
manger on assume d'être surpris c'est
toujours là c'est vrai
non ce n'est pas touché j'ai touché le
radiateur commence pas à avoir des
douleurs qui n'existe pas